Speaker 1: All right, well, I apologize to
everybody who has an allergy to high levels
of cringe, but we do have to talk about C-PAC
over the weekend.
We are going to look at some of the wackiest
moments from C-PAC.
We're going to look at the various speakers
will look at the interviews that Donald Trump
gave before and after his CPAC speech.
But we're going to start with Donald Trump's
completely deranged, unhinged.
Yes, febrile.
It's the last day of February, so it's the
will.
I'll move on to a different adjective in March,
but for February, these are still going to
be described as febrile speeches.
Donald Trump at moments the crowd was engaged
at moments the crowd was completely bored,
but apparently announcing a 2024 run by all
estimations.
Trump is saying he's running in 2024.
Speaker 2: Take a listen.
They're going to find out the hard way starting
on November 8th, and then again, even more
so on November 2024.
They will find out like never before.
We did it twice and we'll do it again.
We're going to be doing it again.
Speaker 1: So this seems as though it is Donald
Trump announcing that he is running for president
in 2024.
All right.
Are we?
I know it's not.
A formal announcement in a formal announcement
would bring with it different sorts of limitations
and financial requirements and reporting and
things with Trump wants to avoid.
But it seems that he's saying he's going to
run Trump kind of bringing out all the hits
that we became used to during his presidency.
One is those sort of weird.
Some people call them like neurological glitches.
It's where Trump messes up a word and sort
of twitches, and it's weird.
Let's take a look at one of those.
There were a handful
Speaker 2: system to persecute you, which
is a persecution.
Speaker 1: And again, we don't know what that
is.
It there's a there's a twitch and he messes
up a word and then tries to get back on track.
We we just don't know what this is, Will.
And you really have to see it.
Let's look at it once more.
Speaker 2: System to persecute you.
You is a person.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
We don't know.
We just we don't know what that is.
Another classic from Trump is the Sir Routines
stories where Trump uses the word sir are
almost always stories.
That didn't happen, sir.
Speaker 2: Sure.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So here's Trump telling one of his serve stories.
Speaker 2: I've had great people come up to
me and tell me, Sir, may I please ask you
a question?
Yes.
What would you like to know, sir?
How did you take it?
How did you take it so much?
Speaker 1: Multiple sirs there.
And that story almost certainly didn't happen.
Trump shouting out his former doctor, who's
now a congressman, a congressman, and talking
about how the doctor got to know every inch
of Trump,
Speaker 2: a man that knows me almost better
than any human being.
He knows every inch of me.
And he thinks it's actually a very beautiful
sight.
Speaker 1: So just very weird.
I mean, I can't say that that's not funny,
but it's just all pretty weird.
Donald Trump then seemingly tries to take
credit for getting the United States out of
Iraq and out of Afghanistan, neither of which
happened while Trump was president.
I mean, I don't know that it matters to him,
but those things didn't happen while he was
president.
Speaker 2: Remember, though, when so many
people in the Democrat Party and during the
debates said he's going to get us into the
Third World War with Trump, I'm the one that
didn't have any wars.
I'm the one that got us out of wars.
Look at Iraq, look at Syria.
I was the one that brought us way down in
Afghanistan.
I brought you down to two thousand soldiers.
The easy part was just getting out.
I brought it down from twenty thousand soldiers
to 2000 soldiers.
The easy part was for Biden to just get him
out, let the soldiers stay the remaining soldiers
and take care of everything.
It's called soldiers out.
Last I went to a child.
Yeah, so
Speaker 1: very, very confusing thing, he
says.
He got us out of Iraq, which he didn't.
He did draw down troops in Afghanistan, but
then he says he left Biden the easy part.
But then Biden should have let him stay, but
it was easy to take him out.
It's all very, very confused.
It doesn't actually make any sense.
Trump, then again telling one of these stories
of where he refers to a Taliban leader as
Abdul.
Now, for a while, when he said when he would
refer to this leader, he would refer to him
as Muhammad.
So it's not clear Trump knows the guy's name.
Or maybe he's using Abdul Slash Muhammad as
a placeholder for it was a Muslim guy.
It's not really clear.
And he tells a story again.
It probably never happened that he showed
a story, a picture of the guy's house as a
threat to the leader.
It's very, very weird.
Speaker 2: But I said, Abdul, you're killing
our soldiers.
You better.
How can I kill ourselves as a.
Because if you do, you will be hit like no
country has ever been hit.
You will be hit harder than anybody
Unidentified: has ever been hit.
Speaker 2: And he said, Mr. President, but
why?
He actually called me, your excellency.
I don't know.
Do you think he calls Biden, Your Excellency
Abadi?
Because but why, your excellency, Mr. President,
do you send me a picture of my house?
And I
said I'd rather not answer that question.
Speaker 1: That almost certainly never, ever,
ever happened.
Trump then tells the lie that again, Hillary
spied on my campaign.
Of course, the crowd demands Hillary be locked
up.
Speaker 2: Now we know that Crooked Hillary
not only spied on my campaign, she spied on
the White House.
Speaker 1: Remember, none of that is true.
That's not what the Durham report filing said,
it's there's no evidence that that's true,
but the crowd doesn't care.
So the crowd chanting Lock her up, and of
course, remember Hillary, these are the people
of law and order and due process.
Hillary Clinton has not even been charged.
Never mind convicted of any crimes.
Locking such a person up is weird.
Then a really unusual contrast happened during
his riffing part because Trump does this thing
during these speeches where he'll read a little
bit of something off the prompter and then
he'll riff.
And in his riff, he criticized the Supreme
Court, which is one third made up of people
he selected and then later off the prompter.
He bragged about how he chose conservatives
to the court.
It's very funny because he doesn't even know
that this is a direct contrast.
So here he is, trying to go to the audience
into booing the Supreme Court justice deficits.
Speaker 2: But even our Supreme Court justices,
and it's sad to say this right are afraid
to do what has to be done to save our country.
They're trying so desperately to be politically
correct and to be loved by all these the justices
of the United States Supreme Court.
Speaker 1: So Trump, they're criticizing the
Supreme Court.
And what he means, guys, is they didn't flip
the election to him.
That's really what he means.
But funny.
Later off the prompter, he brags about how
he selected conservatives to the court.
But these are the conservatives you just attacked.
Speaker 2: And ship, as your president, I
kept my promise and chose Supreme Court justices
on the list I gave to the country before the
2016 election, I gave a list of great, brilliant
conservative justices.
Speaker 1: So they're now taking credit for
the great conservative justices.
And then lastly, and this is the funniest
moment Trump starts reading his closing.
And because Trump struggles to read off of
the teleprompter, he pauses at a weird moment
where it sounds like he's saying, I'm here
today is your president.
Trump was actually about to read a list of
things he did as president, but the crowd
is so weaponized when Trump says as your president,
they think he's saying, I am now your president
and they go crazy cheering and with a standing
ovation, it's beyond parody.
This is a sick cult in summation.
Speaker 2: And in closing, as your president,
I instituted.
Speaker 1: You understand what's happening,
right?
The crowd thinks Trump is saying in summation
as your president, right, he's saying, I'm
here today as your president.
And the crowd cheers.
Remember, if it's Trump alone doing these
things and nobody cares and nobody pays attention,
it's one crazy guy.
When you have a roomful, a movement full of
people who love this stuff, it's just a reminder.
And that's what CPAC was.
Of how sick and dangerous and delusional this
entire movement is in the United States.
That's Trump's speech to CPAC.
Let's now look at a little bit of the sort
of little press conference that Donald Trump
gave